listen closely to the media coverage of
the 36 year old accusation against
Supreme Court nominee Brett Kavanaugh
and the chorus is hard to miss we have
dr. Ford's credible allegation she has
nothing to gain here the receipts were
there the story is credible I don't
think anyone doesn't believe her I have
every reason to believe that she's going
to show that she's a very credible
witness and their story is very credible
I believe dr. Ford as I referred to her
because she makes a very credible case
this is a situation where you have
serious and credible allegations of a
rape now we're led to believe that these
are credible allegations they're all
reading from the same playbook but given
the age of the charges what's the
standard for credibility has any
evidence been produced
is there any corroborating witness so
far the answer is no in fact the only
other person named in the accusation
says it never happened in given what we
know of the accusers political
inclination and her support of left-wing
causes it's not unreasonable to believe
that she has a political axe to grind
the hyperbolic overheated reaction to
these charges is somewhat reminiscent of
what happened to the Duke lacrosse team
more than a decade ago remember in 2006
the Duke lacrosse team hired a pair of
exotic dancers for a party at a rental
house near the Duke campus one of the
dancers a black woman claimed that three
of the lacrosse players brutally raped
her in a bathroom Dave Evans the captain
of the team and one of the accused he
spoke to the media the moment he learned
of the charges against him first I want
to say that I'm absolutely innocent of
all the charges that have been brought
against me today that Reade Seligmann
and Colin family are innocent of all the
charges that were brought against them
every member of the Duke University
lacrosse team is innocent you have all
been told some fantastic lies well the
media seized on the story spinning this
strippers credible accusation into a
tale of white privilege
sajin II and just pure evil a media
swarm and rush to judgment followed the
Duke lacrosse coach Mike Pressler who
stood by his team in the face of these
false allegations was fired for it and
the young men's reputations were dragged
through the mud only later did we
discover that the three accused men were
not near the dancer long enough for the
alleged assault to have happened one of
the three men accused was a mile away at
an ATM machine and thankfully it was
captured on security video at the time
of the alleged incident all three men
were eventually cleared of the charges
North Carolina's then Attorney General
Roy Cooper in declaring their innocence
said the men had been victims of a
tragic rush to accuse and the failure to
verify serious allegations the crusading
Durham District Attorney Mike Fong who
cooked evidence and race to prosecute
was disbarred and convicted of contempt
for his actions now this should be in a
different facts this is a cautionary
tale as we weigh and determine the
credibility of allegations against judge
Cavanaugh at least the Duke Lacrosse
case was kind of contemporary when it
comes to the timing with witnesses and a
crime scene 36 years later miss Ford
can't recall exactly when or where her
alleged incident even took place yet
throughout the media the drumbeat goes
on and on and there is an implicit
message that senators dare not submit
the accuser to any tough questioning as
they did with Anita Hill I remember
sitting in that hearing room watching a
Nita Hill in der character assassination
day after day from Republicans they know
that they can't attack her directly and
say she's making it up that's what they
do with it I need a hill in 1991 today
that probably wouldn't fly in a me-too
era we must not repeat the mistake of
the Anita Hill hearings they were rushed
and were a debacle do we want to repeat
that mistake tabacco I actually
the Republicans have learned the
important lesson from the Anita Hill
hearings they've learned that the only
way to deal with last-minute he said she
said allegations is to refuse to be
intimidated and to proceed fairly and
methodically but the more salient
question is have the Democrats learned
any lessons about the toxicity of false
charges
coupled with the media pile on as
demonstrated by both the Duke Lacrosse
in the Clarence Thomas cases do they
recognize that a rush to judgment is not
only unfair but destructive to the
process and to individual lives every q
sir has a right to speak out but should
be obliged to have his or her
allegations challenged and sometimes
aggressively so the accused meanwhile
should not be presumed guilty and he or
she should have every opportunity to
clear his or her good name now chairman
Grassley has dedicated Monday to a
public hearing where both judge
Cavanaugh and his accuser MS Ford have
been invited to appear Cavanaugh is
ready but according to reports out late
tonight and a letter from her attorney
ms Ford wants the FBI to investigate her
allegations before she agrees to appear
that was a late-breaking letter that her
attorney submitted to the Senate tonight
well the question is who will blink
first listeners to my radio show had a
message today for Republicans who failed
to stand up for Kavanagh in a fair
process if the Republicans don't do this
I'll be voting but I won't be voting for
Republicans they've done this so many
times they have no no facts on their
nose fine
I am infuriated the reason we voted for
Trump is because of his outstanding
SCOTUS pics if they don't push Cavanaugh
through they will never seek another
Supreme Court judge especially a man I
have been traveling all over the country
attending Trump rallies and I can tell
you firsthand if the Republicans don't
grow a backbone and support Cavanaugh
and
take the vote now they're gonna have
hell to pay come November well in a way
though this shouldn't really be about
the midterms right this should only be
about whether judge Cavanaugh is
qualified to sit on the highest court of
the land we all have to ask ourselves
the question should a charge made by one
person decades late impossible to prove
or to rebut be enough to dam the
reputation of someone with decades of
honorable public service someone whose
jobs in government required no fewer
than six previous FBI background checks
and shouldn't all of us regardless of
party consider the poisonous precedent
that that would set and that's the angle